I don't know if you watched me watching
your yay interview yeah thank you so
much for I'm so curious when you're
navigating a conversation like that
are you how intentional is the thought
process between like building Rapport
and pushing and and giving a little like
zero zero attention I was watching and
thank you so much I was very kind for
you to review that conversation it meant
a lot that you were complimenting Parts
on the technical aspects of the
conversation but no zero and I'm
actually deliberately
uh trying to avoid I think you've called
it debate brain uh which is just another
flavor of thinking about
like The Meta conversation trying to
optimize how should this conversation go
because I feel like the more you do that
the better you get at that
the less human connection you have like
the less genuinely you're actually
sitting there in the moment and
listening to the person you're more like
calculating what's the right thing to
say versus like feeling what is uh what
is that person feeling right now what
are they thinking that's what I'm trying
to do is like putting myself
in their mind and thinking what does the
world look like to them what does the
world feel like to them and so from that
I truly try to listen now I'm also
learning especially because Rogan and
others have been giving me [ __ ] for not
pushing back it's good sometimes to say
from a place of care for the other human
being to say stop
what did you just say I don't think
that's represents who you are and what
you really mean or maybe
if it does at that time represents who
they are
I could see a better
a better world if they grow into a
different direction and try to point
that direction out to them it was a
really complicated dance between letting
somebody share their full story versus
letting somebody like essentially I
guess like proselytize your audience and
it's like okay hold on let's take a
minute here but yeah I used to be four
or five years ago it was attack attack
attack attack whatever you said and now
I'm leaning way more towards the like
okay well tell me how you feel about
everything and then we'll go from there
so a lot of people like my new approach
some older fans will watch and they're
like why are you letting this guy just
Ramble On you know he said like five or
six wrong things and you're only gonna
call them out on two of them and it's
like it's different styles of
conversation but you know do you do a
lot of research beforehand too depending
on the conversation yeah so if we're
going to talk like vaccines and stuff
yeah that's a ton of reading and stuff
that I never thought I'd know going into
it um if it's a more personal like
political philosophy conversation
there's not as much you can prepare for
just it truly depends on the
conversation how much are you actually
listening to the other person I'm always
listening you have to listen because as
soon as you stop listening the quality
of everything falls apart the connection
disappears the quality the conversation
disappears but my natural inclination is
to just be way more aggressive than
normal so I have to constantly remind
myself I guess you would call it a meta
conversation when you're like okay he's
probably saying this because of that or
we'll let him go here and then we'll
stop later but um yeah because my my
preferred style of conversation is like
I'm gonna talk and the second I say
something you disagree with then let's
iron it out right like I think in like
syllogisms like okay here's the premise
a good okay premise B okay and then
conclusion and then as long as we're
both deductively sound we're not crazy
no psychosis then we're gonna agree on
everything whereas other people like to
most people think in stories like
narratives like a whole there's a whole
like narrative and the individual facts
don't matter as much because they'll
pick and choose what they want and it's
really hard because everybody thinks
narratives don't have to function in
that world but it's uh frustrating for
me sometimes well I've seen uh you've
had a lot of excellent debates one of
them I just recently last night watched
is a on systemic racism and it's the
first time I've seen you completely lose
your [ __ ] oh shoot who was that against
I'm not sure exactly but you were just
very frustrated and sorry not lose your
[ __ ] but you're frustrated constantly
because of the thing let's lay out one
two three and every time you try to lay
it out it would falter I think it had to
do with sort of can you use data to make
an argument or do you need to use a
study that does an interpretation of
that data and then there's like this
tension between I think this is a
behavioral Economist that you were
talking to and the point is you do this
kind of nice layout that the whole point
of Behavioral economics is says there's
more to it than just the data you have
to give the context and like do the rich
rigorous interpretation in the context
of the full human story and then there
was like a dance back before sometimes
use data sometimes not and you're
getting really frustrated and shutting
down and so that felt like a failure
mode I've seen Sam Harris have similar
sticking points like if we can't agree
on the terminology we can't go on to me
I feel like uh I'm just sort of the the
winkenstein perspective is like
I think if you get stuck on any one
thing you're just not going to make
progress you have to
part of the conversation has to be
about
uh doing a good dance together
versus being dogmatically stuck on the
path to truth I think the true challenge
is identifying what of those sticking
points are important versus what is not
important it's like if I'm having an
argument with somebody about like Jewish
representation and media they might it
might be like a big conversation and
they might say a couple things like I
think Jewish people you know they tend
to help their own or whatever they're
saying okay but like for the purpose of
the conversation we can keep moving but
if they casually drop like you know yeah
and I think that's why the Holocaust
numbers are blown up from like a hundred
thousand to six million and that's why I
was like okay hold on wait if you think
this we have to stop here because this
is going to be it's not just a language
game in this part if you really believe
this fact then the whole rest of the
conversation is going to be informed by
that belief you know and it has to be
something that doesn't bother you
personally you have to step outside your
own ego
so holga's denial is somebody that would
bother a lot of people and there's some
things just just observing you I feel
like when you get really good at
conversation you can become a stickler
to
um you might have your favorite terms
that really bothers you people don't
agree on those terms begs the question
you mean raising the question yeah I
usually just want if people say stuff I
just let it slide yeah you can't because
if you fight when you're having a
conversation with somebody and you're
talking to their audience at the same
time because that's really what's
happening um you never want to come off
as over combative or over aggressive
because it puts people in like there's
there's like a trigger in your brain and
this is true of relationships and
friendships of persuasive rhetoric or
whatever there's a trigger in the brain
and as soon as that defensive trigger
gets like flipped on everything is over
you've lost the ability to persuade
because everything becomes a fight at
that point